hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the 1857 first
American chess Congress and we are
continuing to match the finals of the
first American chess Congress Paul
Charles Murphy vs. Louis Paulsen after
the legendary game six we are back at
game 7 and this is quite a weird one the
beginning is is incredibly weird and the
ending is incredibly weird but you'll
see what I mean by this and I gave up on
the whole fortnight idea it was a
spur-of-the-moment thing after I slept
on it I decided that maybe I'll just
stick to chess so without further ado
let's check it out morphia again opens
with E 4 we have C 5 Paulsen for the
third time in the match goes for the
Sicilian defense 9 3 e 6 and D 4 so the
same as in game 4 in game five we have
captures captures and Bishop to c5 and
the Polson variation as Paulsen himself
is playing it Bishop to e3 and the now
comes Queen to b6 and here in game 4 the
one that more if you want he went
tonight the b5 he offered this exchange
captures captures captures and Bishop to
e2 which isn't really good for black but
Paul still declined but here more if he
goes for Knight to c3 he just continues
development and he offers the b2 pawn
now is this is this pawn poisoned or not
it's it's a good question but whether
it's poisoned or not still Queen
captures and BTO Paulsen captures it and
now feel free to pause the video and
punish Paulsen for this early insolence
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting that the pawn
was indeed poisoned and that the Queen
should be trapped and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show its
Knight d2 b5 point is you are now
defending your knight here the Queen
defends the rook and there really is no
defense against rook to b1 which traps
the Queen now interestingly there is one
game from 2004 that reached this exact
same position where black tried Bishop
to b4
saying that okay maybe I'll capture and
then after you recapture with the night
I can run away but it doesn't really
work after Bishop to b2 the threat still
remains of rook to b1 and if you trade
here you wypall just capture with
and the queen is still trapped so
there's nowhere nowhere to go
so that's bad news for paulsen but after
more fees 992 b5 pause and capture than
III and here it is as a move seventh at
this position was never reached again
and for good reasons and more if we just
continues rook to b1 and the queen is
trapped so it makes you wonder why why
didn't more if you try this in the first
two games were poles and played the
Sicilian but now there is no good reply
here more features gives up sort of
pulse and gives up the Queen Queen
captures an b1 Knight captures and now
Bishop to F for getting the - powdered
way preventing night the c7 check by
morphe and the loss of further material
and it's not all that all that bad
Posehn still did grab a piece and the
rook but all of his pieces are still
undeveloped and he has a lot to prove if
he thinks he can still play this game
but okay g3 and we have a six now
Paulsen of course doesn't want to move
the bishop best he still needs to defend
the c7 square more if he captures he
doesn't mind trading now as he is of
material 8 characters in the now Knight
to c3 going after the b5 pawn Knight the
e7 Paulson prepares maybe the castle and
mountain Knight captures on b5 preparing
either check the window to win the rook
or just Knight to d6 at the hinder
Black's development with castles by
Paulson and now Knight to d6 and now
like I said Paulsen did grab some
material for the Queen but his pieces
are completely undeveloped Knight B to
c6 he continued his development looked
the g1 of course more if he puts the
Brooke on a semi open file and rook
captures an a2 now grabbing the pawn but
it's really not the greatest pawn to
grab as you'll see a morphic continues
with f5 and now the thread is just f6
busting open the position problem is if
you play something like captures
captures and f6 hoping that you will
stop the attack just Bishop c4 Turk
picks up the rook so that's not even an
option
so after f5 we have f6 preventing f6 now
but here morphe goes for bush of the c4
put more pressure on e6 also puts the
bishop on this diagonal attacks the rook
look the a for attacking the bishop and
now as there are a lot of ways you could
continue this more he first place F for
grabs more space prevents the knight
from coming to e5 and it's really hard
for black to develop his pieces but okay
Paulsen here played b6 he wants to
develop his light square bishop but
there is a move that he could have
played which is which is kind of better
and I will ask you to pause the video
here and try to find it black black will
still be worse but it's it's a very
important technique to have to be able
to play the play the best move even when
you're worse so feel free to pause the
video once again while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who found it congratulations on being a
stubborn defender and for those of you
who just wanna enjoy the show it's not
b6 but rather b5 and now the point is
what do you do here if you move the
bishop then you just continue it
captures on f5 and the bishop will at
some point leave this diagonal or you
will go brush up the b3 then rook the d4
comes with an attack on the Queen you do
get some development in and lastly but
not leastly if you capture on b5 then
again rogue d4 puts pressure on the
Queen and after Queen g4 threatening
mate now you go g6 captures captures and
white is still better of course but you
you you were able to get some pieces
into the game the rook is nicely placed
on b4 threatening the knight and d6 so
white will have to move it at some point
and it's not all that lost just yet
however b6 by pulsing much slower but
now more free just continues F captures
any six D captures on e6 and now Morphy
goes for the for the simplest possible
solution
he plays Knight captures on c8 we have
Knight captures on c8 removing the
defender of the six pawn bishop
characters and e6 check King to h8 and
now Morphy has to go for either Bishop
to d5 to get the strength in his
position a bit
defendi e4 pawn or just straight-up
Queen to g4 threatening mate and after
which is pretty much forced okay one
check you can trade rooks here captures
captures now the knight can go here
let's say and the
continues but now the game is winning
for white so this is what more if you
should should have gone for however
Morphy played well maybe not the worst
possible move the worst possible move
was maybe Quinta da just giving up a
queen morphe played Bishop characters in
c8 and this is just bad because more
important captures with the rook and
more if it goes for Queen to d7 and it
does make sense puts pressure on the
rook also threatens checkmate if the
knight moves you can capture this rook
so it does make sense and I'm gonna use
this for the thumbnail so it looks looks
pretty nice but it actually gives pulse
and a chance to draw the game so feel
free to pause the video and find this
elusive draw but both of them probably
missed well I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting a draw in a seemingly lost
position and for those who just wanna
enjoy show its rook captures any four
check first and after the King moves
like the king of ticking f1 doesn't
really matter now Knights the e7
defending mate the knight defends the
rook and what do you play here rook
captures and c2 is coming and there's
not much you can do about this
for example rook to e1 you go after you
go after the rook you want to trade some
pieces just rook captures and c2 with
check King f1 you have to defend your
rook here but now just captures captures
and after night the g8 you will not be
winning this game as white as there's
black simply has too many resources the
knight and g it is a beautiful defender
you cannot get past f6 you will not pass
h6 as the knight defends it and there's
not much to do here the white king
cannot come into the game as the route
controls the second-ranked
you might try pushing h4 but doesn't
really matter
rook h2o it's a queen g4 defense now you
start pushing b5 h5 b4 and there's not
much you can do b b3 king c1 you're
gonna go Roxy to check in v1 route goes
back it defends the pawn and it there's
no way for white to make progress so by
going for the simplest possible idea
in other words giving pulse and zero
respect whatsoever
morphia allowed pulse in this drawing
opportunity however morphe Paulsen plays
a
a different move he plays you could go
for some like rook to Jade but then you
give up the night so person instead goes
Knight to e7 and although this is the
engines third recommendation it doesn't
really do anything since the game is
completely lost no more if you could
just grab the rook and say okay what do
you have now there's nothing to play I
defend the c2 pawn it's completely lost
but morph instead after Knight to e7
goes for Queen captures on e7 even
allows him to capture and c2 and give
rook e1 check but doesn't really matter
we have looked a one check by Paul Simon
king f2 rook captures and c2 with Czech
king to e3 and it was in this position
that we post and resign the game and yet
another victory for Paul Morphy in the
finals of the first American chess
congress in this very weird game 7 there
is not much to do here if you capture
well there's obviously this made threat
if you captured the rook then it's just
a back rank mate if there's no rookie
three check to continue marching the
king of the board as the Queen covers
that so they're really they really are
no moves here for black of course
Paulsen resigned and well it you know
it's it was a good game Paulsen
blundered his Queen very early on but it
really seems like Murphy was giving
Paulson zero respect for that he just
went for the simplest idea probably
didn't even check if he had any options
if he didn't want to calculate he could
have just played Bishop to b5 like we
said guards d4 pawn and there's nothing
important can do but he did give him
chances and this is just something that
this is 1857 even though players like
Murphy Adolph Anderson and a lot of
other brilliant attackers were just
brilliant attackers creating blistering
attacks and beautiful combinations they
weren't really all that great when it
came to defending so if you came came at
them you know chances are you would have
you would have won the game but yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Hyder Kadeem Ali
Assad now David Oliver Karen Lucas
Williams and Henry neo Stein for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Morphy saga we have one more game in the
first American chess congress before me
we move on checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world which is pretty much
what happens online at the moment but
yeah I have some exciting news in the
next video which I will also post today
so stay tuned and yeah
like I said I hope you enjoyed it and I
will see you guys soon